Now that the rational zero test has given us eight possibilities for zeroes at
this function. Why don't we test some of them out? Now, of course, figuring out
the value of the function at any of these values for x will give us useful
information. But right now, I'm really only interested in which ones of these,
when plugged into our function, give us f of x 0. Or rather, f of whatever
value we plug in equals 0. Here's how we're going to go about doing this. I've
made a list of the values of the function at all the possible zeroes we had,
and I'd like you to evaluate all of these function values. All you need to do
for this quiz is, starting at the top of the list, work your way down, and as
soon as you find a value of the function that equals 0, write a 0 in the box
next to that value. You can leave all the other boxes blank, and remember, you
can stop after you have found just one zero. The top most one.